la tarea no es simple pero hablando de
ciertamente no tenemos alternativa el
esfuerzo debe empezar
con el esfuerzo a nuestros países
domésticamente en primer lugar es lo que
hacemos al nivel doméstico que nos da la
medida de la autoridad con la cual
actuamos a nivel internacional
así permítanme hablar desde la
perspectiva de mi país cuando brasil
habla de sus perspectivas
de la salud pública lo hacemos con la
autoridad legítima de un gobierno que
durante la pandemia cohen 19 no se
guarda ningún esfuerzo para salvar vidas
y preservar trabajos
como tantos otros países
enfocamos nuestra atención desde el
inicio
en asegurarnos ayuda financiera de
emergencia para aquellos que más lo
necesitaban nuestra meta fue proteger a
las familias el ingreso de las familias
para que
puedan enfrentar dificultades económicas
resultantes de la pandemia
así
logramos beneficiar a más de 68 millones
de personas el equivalente a un tercio
de la población brasileña en paralelo
lanzamos una programa amplio de vacunas
incluyendo la producción doméstica de
vacunas somos una nación
de más de 210 millones de personas y ya
tenemos más del 80% de nuestra población
vacunada completamente en contra del cob
y 19 todos fueron vacunados
voluntariamente con el debido respeto de
la libertad individual a sí mismo en la
arena económica brasil y tiene la
autoridad legítima de un país que por el
bien de los el crecimiento sostenible e
inclusivo ha dado a conocer reformas
para atraer inversión y mejorar los
estándares los estándares de vida de su
población bajo de administración
acabamos con la corrupción sistémica que
existía en el país
entre 2003 y 2015 nada más un período en
el que la izquierda presidió al brasil
aumentó los niveles
de corrección en petrobras
una hora de malversación de fondos eso
llegó a cientos de millones la persona
responsable por eso fue
impresionado por la cárcel
se le ha pagado 2000 de millones por
deudas se han devuelto dinero pero es el
brasil del pasado
hemos mejorado los servicios públicos al
mejorar los costos al invertir en
ciencia y tecnología y hoy por ejemplo
brasil
es el país avanzado digitalmente número
135 millón de personas tienen acceso a
cientos de servicios propias por mi
administración brasil ha sido pionero en
despliegue 5g en latinoamérica también
hemos ejecutado una agenda comprensiva
de privatización y de proyectos en
concesión con énfasis en infraestructura
también hemos completado
el proyecto de transposición en el río
san francisco llevando agua a la región
noreste de ver si también hemos adoptado
nuevos marcos reguladores en temas de
salud vías de riel
también hemos mejorado el ambiente de
negocios con la ley de libertad
económica y la ley de startups como
resultado ahora
hemos creado oportunidades para jóvenes
para que ellos sean empresarios para que
tengan trabajos de calidad
por encima de todos estos esfuerzos para
modernizar la economía brasileña
hemos logrado grandes avances en el
acceso de brasil a la organización de
cooperación económica y desarrollo de la
ocde
a pesar de la crisis global brasil está
llegando al final de 2022 con una
economía en una recuperación casi que
completa tenemos altas
tasas de recuperación y baja inflación
la economía está en el camino del
crecimiento la pobreza ha incrementado
en todo el mundo bajo el impacto de la
pandemia en brasil
empezó a decaer
las cifras las cifras hablan solas se
estima que para el final de 2022 el 4
por ciento de las familias brasileñas
estarán viviendo
por debajo del nivel de pobreza extrema
en 2019 era el 5 por ciento esto es una
disminución de más del 20% se diseñó un
sistema de ingreso mínimo
que actualmente resuelve las necesidades
de 20 millones de familias y paga
alrededor de 4 mil dólares al día para
las cabinas de los pobres
el empleo llego al 5.9
una tasa que no se veía en siete años
hemos disminuido también la inflación no
estimado de menos de 7% para 2022 me
complace anunciar que hemos tenido
una deflación sin precedentes en los
meses de julio y agosto de este año
desde junio el precio de la gasolina ha
disminuido por más de 30 por ciento
hoy un litro de gasolina cuesta
0.9 dólares el precio electricidad
también ha disminuido por más de 15 por
ciento quiero hacer énfasis en que el
costo de la energía no se ha disminuido
por
los precios fijados porque no ha habido
intervención estatal es más un resultado
de una racionalización una política
implementada con el respaldo del
congreso nacional
en 2021 brasil fue el cuarto
destino de inversión directa
nuestro ministerio de comercio habló de
una meta increíble el 30 por ciento del
producto interno bruto incluso después
de los impuestos
en miles de productos domésticamente
también tenemos récords en tres áreas
recolección de impuestos
ganancias de empresas
estatales y una mejoría del pib
el producto interno bruto de brasil
incremento en 1.2 por ciento y se prevé
que en 2022 sea del 3%
estamos disfrutando de tranquilidad de
aquellos que están trabajando en el
camino correcto el camino de compartir
la prosperidad entre otras y más allá de
eso la prosperidad
que se comparte con esos vecinos y con
otros socios en todo el mundo
esto es lo que vemos
en temas alimentarios hace cuatro
décadas brasil solía ser un importador
de comida y hoy somos uno de los mayores
exportadores del mundo y esto solamente
ha sido posible gracias a las fuertes
inversiones en ciencia e innovación con
la búsqueda de aumentar la productividad
y la sostenibilidad
quiero darle tributo al señor allison
perry nelly el candidato brasileño del
premio nobel de paz por su rol en
expandir la agricultura brasileña con el
uso de nuevas tecnologías
este año brasil ya empezó la cosecha la
cosecha más grande de grano en nuestra
historia estimamos que sea de al menos
270 millones de toneladas unos cuantos
años brasil también hará la transición
de importaciones a exportaciones el
proceso 2022 2023 se prevé que se
excedan las 200 millones de toneladas
como se dijo en la provincia sin multar
el comercio en su visita a brasil si no
fuese por el negocio brasileño del
planeta hubiera quedado en hambre porque
alimentamos a miles de millones de
personas al revés del mundo nuestro
negocio agricultura es una fuente de
orgullo nacional señor presidente
también quiero hablar de que
frente al desarrollo sostenible el
récord de brasil de logros es una gran
fuente de credibilidad para nuestro las
acciones e intenciones de nuestro país
respecto del medio ambiente y el
desarrollo sostenible brasil es parte de
esa solución
y eso se convierte en una referencia
para el resto del mundo dos tercios de
todo territorio brasileño sigue sin ser
tocado cubierto por vegetación nativa
precisamente como estaba cuando brasil
fue descubierto en los 1500 en la región
amazónica brasileña un área tan grande
como el oeste de europa más del
88 por ciento del bosque húmedo sigue
siendo prístino contrario a lo que se
reporta en los medios nacionales e
internacionales es clave y esencial que
cuando se cuida el medio ambiente no
dejemos de observar a la gente la región
amazónica del hogar de 20 mil de
personas pueblos indígenas y colonos
cuya vida depende de
alguna forma de aprovechamiento
económico del bosque
hemos llevado conectividad de internet a
más de
100 mil escuelas rurales en más de
comunidades de más de gentes comunidades
indígenas brasil empezó su transición
energética hacia el menos medio siglo en
respuesta a la crisis petrolera de esa
época hoy
tenemos
una industria de biocombustibles moderna
y sostenible una industria que
contribuye positivamente
constantemente
a nuestra imagen como el país más limpio
del g20 un gran porcentaje de nuestra
energía es renovable y eso es una meta
que muchos países en desarrollo esperan
lograr
solamente después de 2040 y 2050
el año pasado brasil fue elegida o
declarada por las naciones unidas
como
un ejemplo de transición energética
tenemos el potencial de convirtiéndose
en un exportador global de energía
limpia tenemos un excedente que ya se
está logrando y puede llegar incluso
hasta
los 100 watts entre
biomasa proyectos solares proyectos
eólicos sin considerar las oportunidades
no discutidas
con uno de los costos de producción más
bajo del mundo estas fuentes producirán
de hidrógeno verde para la exportación
parte de esta
este enfoque nos convierte en
competidores a nivel mundial proyectos
industriales particularmente en el
noreste brasileño
con uno de
las menores huella de carbono en el
mundo
el desarrollo sostenible la gente
impactado es impactada por amenazas a la
paz y la seguridad en todo el mundo
todos hemos construido las naciones
unidas desde las ruinas de la segunda
guerra mundial en el último siglo lo que
nos motivó en ese momento fue la
determinación de evitar la repetición
del ciclo de destrucción que marcó la
primera mitad del siglo 20
en cierto punto perspectiva podríamos
decir que fuimos exitosos
pero hoy el conflicto en ucrania sirve
como una advertencia
una reforma del sistema naciones unidas-
es esencial
para que encontremos la paz mundial en
este caso específico del consejo de
seguridad después de 25 años de debate
es claro que debemos
observar buscar soluciones innovadoras
brasil se enfrenta a este tema basados
en una experiencia que viene el inicio
de las naciones unidas
es la onceava vez que hemos tenido un
acento no permanente de disco se va
seguridad y hemos buscado ofrecer lo
mejor posible para llegar a soluciones
pacíficas y negociadas al conflicto
internacional siempre guiados por la
carta de las naciones unidas y la ley
internacional brasil también tiene una
historia larga de participación en
operaciones de sostenimiento de paz de
angola haití líbano siempre hemos
participado y siempre hemos respaldado
el sostenimiento de la paz también hemos
contribuido a la paz al abrir nuestras
fronteras para aquellos que buscan una
oportunidad de red iniciar sus vidas en
nuestro país desde 2018 más de 6
millones de hermanos venezolanos
se han visto forzados a abandonar su
país muchos de ellos llegaron a brasil
nuestra respuesta a este desafío fue la
operación bienvenida que se ha
convertido en una referencia
internacional más de 350.000 venezolanos
han encontrado el territorio brasileño
asistencia de emergencia protección
documentación y la posibilidad de un
inicio fresco todos han tenido acceso al
mercado laboral de los servicios
públicos y a los beneficios sociales
en meses recientes
cerca de 600 venezolanos han llegado a
brasil cada día a pie la vasta mayoría
mujeres y niños
que pesan
60 kilos menos que antes que huyen de la
violencia del hambre la recepción la
política de recepción humanitaria en
brasil va más allá de venezuela también
hemos recibido haitianos sirios
africanos y ucranianos señor presidente
el conflicto en ucrania ha estado
pasando ocurriendo por 7 meses y así es
una fuente de grave preocupación no
solamente para europa sino para todo el
mundo en primer lugar quisiera reiterar
la gratitud de brasil para los países
que me ha ayudado con la evacuación de
brasileños cuando el conflicto empezó
allí en ucrania
especialmente eslovaquia hungría polonia
rumanía y la república checa muchas
gracias a la operación evacuación fue
exitosa no dejamos a nadie atrás ni
siquiera a sus mascotas
respecto del conflicto en sí mismo
brasil
ha sido guiada por los principios de ley
internacional y la carta de las naciones
unidas principios que también están en
nuestra constitución nacionales nosotros
pedimos un cese al fuego inmediato la
protección de civiles y no combatientes
la preservación de infraestructura
crítica para asistir a la población y el
mantenimiento de todos los canales de
diálogo entre las partes en conflicto
esos son los primeros pasos para lograr
una solución que será duradera y
sostenible
hemos estado trabajando en esta
dirección en las naciones unidades y
también en otras partes
hemos intentado evitar
interrumpir los cambios de diálogo como
resultado de la polarización en este
conflicto junto a eso estamos en contra
del estacionamiento de sí mismo
los efectos del conflicto no pueden
sentirse en el mundo los precios puede
servirse en el mundo los precios del
alimento el combustible se ha sentido
todo esto nos aleja de las metas de
desarrollo sostenible países que se
presentaron en algún momento como
líderes de la economía baja en carbono
ahora han pasado a fuentes sucias de la
energía y esto es un golpe para el medio
ambiente respaldamos todos los esfuerzos
para reducir los impactos económicos de
esta crisis pero no creemos que el mejor
camino sea adoptar
sanciones unilaterales que sean
inconsistentes con la ley internacional
esas medidas han herido la recuperación
económica y han amenazado los derechos
humanos de poblaciones vulnerables
incluyendo a los países europeos esta
solución al conflicto en ucrania
solamente será lograda a través de la
negociación y el diálogo
estoy pidiéndole a estas partes así como
a la comunidad internacional que no
perdamos ninguna oportunidad de acabar
el conflicto y asegurar que ocurra la
paz
la estabilidad de seguridad y la
prosperidad de la humanidad están en
peligro si el conflicto continúa
señor presidente
he sido un partidario incondicional de
la libertad
brasil ha hecho un esfuerzo para que
haya también la libertad de religión en
el país en la agenda es importante que
todo el mundo tenga derecho a practicar
ahora a practicar su orientación
religiosa sin ningún tipo de
discriminación quisiera informar acá que
brasil está lista para dar la bienvenida
a los padres católicos a las monjas
que han sufrido persecución por parte
del régimen dictatorial en nicaragua
brasil repudia de la persecución
religiosa donde sea que ocurre en el
mundo
otras valores fundamentales para la
social brasileña con implicaciones a la
agenda de derechos humanos incluye la
defensa de valores familiares el derecho
a la vida desde la concepción el derecho
a la autodefensa
y la reputación el repudio a la
ideología de género también quisiera
resaltar otra importancia
otro importante enfoque que es la
protección las mujeres también se
sancionaron 70 normas en este tema desde
el inicio de mi administración 2019 es
una evidencia bastante clara de ese
compromiso
combatimos la violencia contra las
mujeres de manera muy estricta
es una en estas verdades para asegurar
que haya seguridad pública para todos
los brasileños los resultados son
visibles
77% disminución en el asesinato de
mujeres y una disminución en la muerte
generales por asesinatos 2017
miles de muertes por habitante ahora y
solamente 17 la violencia en áreas
rurales también ha decrecido a la vez
que la tenencia de la tierra por gente
personas en necesidad de aumentado
administración hemos entregado
400.000 títulos rurales
80% se le han dado a las mujeres siempre
si trabajamos para asegurarnos de tener
mujeres fuertes independientes para que
puedan llegar a donde quieren llegar en
primer lugar mi esposa michelle
ha brindado un nuevo significado al
trabajo voluntario desde 2019 con
atenciones especiales las personas con
discapacidades enfermedades raras señor
presidente señor secreto general jefes
de estado y de gobierno damas y
caballeros
septiembre pasado el siete de septiembre
brasil celebró 200 años de historia como
nación independiente millones de
brasileños salieron a las calles
llamados por su gobierno usando los
colores de su bandera de nuestra bandera
fue la mayor demostración cívica en la
historia de nuestro país las personas
que creen en dios en la tierra en la
familia y en la libertad muchas gracias
a todos